in a Clash of Kings Daenerys Targaryen
meets three seekers pyaari Zara zoom and
axles and Quaithe who are kind of like
the three wise men of the Bible they
come after a miraculous birth beneath a
special star and give gifts to a
possible prophesied Savior but anyway
Pierre pre is a douchebag warlock de
Zara's Owen Duck Sauce is a douchebag
merchant Prince Kai and Quaithe is a
mystery
she wears a red mask and calls herself
quaithe of the shadow like Melisandre
she says she's a shadow binder from a
shy a shadow binder seems to be someone
who uses shadow magic like Mel does to
kill Renly and Courtney Penrose and a
shine is a city at the edge of the known
world steeped in darkness and magic and
mystery
much like quaithe herself beyond her
name and where she's from we know
nothing about this woman yet she
repeatedly appears did any offering
cryptic advice
what's a deal in Qarth quaithe tells
Danny to beware of all who might want to
take her dragons which as Jorah says is
good advice later she says magic is
becoming more powerful in the world of
Ice and Fire which is something with her
before but she implies that it's
happening because of the birth of
Danny's dragons then Quaithe tells Danny
to leave Qarth
Dany asks where she should go and Quay
says this to go north you must journey
south to reach the West
you must go east to go forward you must
go back and to touch the light you must
pass beneath the shadow at first Danny
thinks this means quite the one so to go
to ash I which is after all easternmost
and southernmost of the great cities of
the known world so she asks what is
there in a Shire that I will not find in
Qarth and quake just says truth it's
probably possible for Danny to go to a
Shire it's about as close to Carthage
marina's some suggest Danny might pass
through a Shia go all the way east and
approach Westeros from the West but
there's good reason not to believe that
Danny goes to ash I george RR martin has
said that we will see ash i only in
flashback and memory if at all further
it seems really silly to have such a
cryptic riddle solved immediately after
we hear it right so it seems unlikely
the quaithe means for Danny to go to a
show but she means something important
because in the next book in slavers Bay
quaithe appears to Danny again seemingly
in a dream and repeats the go back to go
forward thing in dance quaithe appears a
third time and this is where she speaks
the most Danny asks quite if she's
dreaming and Quaithe says no but she
also says that she's not actually there
and that only Danny can see her she then
says the glass candles are burning this
may explain how Quay keeps appearing to
Danny when she sleeps glass candles are
magical Valyrian artefacts that allow
communication of along distances kind of
like pollen teary in Lord of the Rings
or just like phones but glass candles
according to mum when the mage allow you
to enter a man's dreams and give him
visions which sounds like what's
happening to Danny and it's plausible
the Quaithe might have a glass candle
it's not like that super rare the maces
of the Citadel have a bunch the
Targaryen szávay Mons day seem to have
had some and someone called guru Thor
nightwalker has some in Qarth where
Quaithe presumably still is so it looks
like Quaithe is using a glass candle to
communicate with Danny
that's one puzzle solved but Quaithe
gives us more she says soon come to the
pale mare and after her the others
Kraken and dark flame lion and Griffon
the Sun Sun and the mummer's dragon
trust none of them remember the undying
beware the perfume seneschal this is
basically a list of everything and
everyone danny has to deal with the pale
mare is the disease that ravages slavers
Bay the others probably the young guy yi
the Krakens Victarion and maybe urine
the dark flame is mokoro the lion Tyrion
the Gryphon Jon connington the son son
Quentyn Martell the mummer's dragon is
probably Aegon may be hinting that he's
no true Targaryen and the perfume
seneschal could be a bunch of stuff
maybe Reznick or Varys or the ship
Tyrion was on interestingly Quaithe
mentions all these people but not Marwan
the mage who is also coming for Dany and
it just so happens that Marwan uses a
glass candle could he be in contact with
Quaithe in any case over all that
stuff's pretty straightforward and
pretty accurate to it right Dany notices
that quaithe predicts the pale mare and
Quentin but she still doesn't understand
the go back to go forward stuff
everything starts to make sense in
Daenerys 10 a dance with dragons in this
chapter danny has a climactic
into the Vision Quest at the edge of the
Dothraki sea she eats some funny berries
flies around on dragon hallucinates a
lot like that scene in Tunisia's D
actually but the point of this for Dany
is a huge turning point in her character
all through dance she tries to
peacefully and diplomatically rule the
city of marine she marries his Darwin
she wants to Aria she chains away her
dragons when she wants them free she
opens des knacks pit and allows yunkish
slavery though she thinks it's wrong
all the while telling herself if I look
back I am lost that's the mantra by
which she suppresses the violent
uncompromising side of her personality
the Doug Aryan side and that's how this
chapter starts she tells herself her
home is in Mereen she needs to bend
before the whip if she looks back she is
lost but in this chapter she looks back
Quaithe appears and says remember who
you are the dragons know to you and her
vision quest begins a vision of visitors
reminds her of her Targaryen blood the
grass reminds her that her dragons are
her true children a vision of Jorah
reminds her that marine is not her home
that her war is in Westeros he says
remember your words and Danny says fire
and blood so at the conclusion of this
chapter
Daenerys says to go forward I must go
back she flies off on dragon hunts and
it's a horse thinks of Daario and the
chapter ends with the appearance of a
Dothraki khalasar Dany is going back to
the Dothraki back to the tug Aaron's
back to fire and blood and it all starts
with quaithe this is what Quaithe means
when she says to go forward you must go
back and the go north to go south and
east go west staff presumably means the
same thing just a little more poetically
admittedly the bit saying to touch the
light you must pass beneath the shadow
doesn't really fit this interpretation
very well the fact that Ash is called a
shine by the shadow does make it
tempting to believe that this means Dany
will go to a shine but again that seems
unlikely
so maybe the light and shadow stuff will
make more sense later for now we've got
a pretty good explanation of Gretz
prophecy to go forward you must go back
refers to a transformation of Danny's
character a return to violence and power
and fire and blood maybe she'll lead a
horde of Dothraki
maybe she'll go burn our enemies in
slavers Bay maybe she'll finally go to
Westeros and maybe
with a loss of her gentler side she'll
become a bit of a bad guy this is a big
deal for Danny but we still don't know
what's up with Quaithe who is she and
what does she want to answer these
questions let's go back to the reign of
King Aegon the fourth Targaryen more
than a hundred years ago known as the
unworthy Aegon famously fathered lots of
bastards including the original Daenerys
Targaryen after whom our Dany is named
but he also fathered someone called
shiera seastar who according to one
theory is Quaithe now for Quaithe to be
shiera she'd have to be more than a
hundred years old but funnily enough
shiera seastar half brother and lover
was Brynden rivers aka bloodraven aka
the three-eyed crow who bran finds alive
beyond the wall and who like Laith gives
cryptic guidance from afar if brendan
extended his life and was close with
shayera maybe she era could extend her
life - of course quake is not a tree
person but the world of arson fire says
she eras mother was said to be a
sorceress and George our Martin has said
that she era was reputed to practice the
dark arts the same is said in the sworn
sword specifically that she bathed in
blood to keep her beauty so it seems
totally possible that she era might
magically extend her life further there
are strong symbolic connections between
her and gwaith she era is associated
with stars her mother named her star of
the sea an intern heiress 10 in the
Dothraki sea the stars whisper quits
prophecy to Danny and Danny sees Quaithe
as a mask made of starlight quits whole
role in the story is symbolically that
of a sea star a guiding light that shows
done either way when she's lost on the
Dothraki sea being shayera may explain
quite smote evasions it makes sense that
a fellow daguerreian princess so
legitimized bastard whatever would want
to guide Dany back to a Targaryen roots
and return to Westeros also shiera is
said to have spoken a dozen languages
and surrounded herself with ancient
scrolls
you got a wander might some of those
ancient scrolls have said something
about a savior called azor Ahai that
prophecy seems to come from a shy so
maybe she Eris Easter went to ash I for
that reason and she helps Danny because
like Panero and a mon she thinks Danny
is azor Ahai or she might have just gone
to a shy
general shadow binding black artsy stuff
well maybe she's never even been to a
shy and she just says she has and wears
a mask and takes the name of quaithe to
hide her identity she was a famed beauty
in her day maybe she doesn't want to be
recognized maybe she had to leave
Westeros to hide her unnaturally long
life we could speculate all day the
point is that there's fairly strong
evidence that quaithe may be shiera
seastar it's far from certain some
things don't fit like Sierra's eyes are
different colors and Danny doesn't
notice that in quake but there are still
strong symbolic connections between the
two and being Sierra may explain quoits
motivations whoever she is quits
prophecy seems to refer to a
transformation in Daenerys as character
from peace and restraint to fire and
blood thanks for watching let me know in
the comments whether you think waithe's
shiera seastar and what topic you'd like
to see next
you